we are all set for first pitch from here
in arlington game seven between the
braves and the dodgers and we mentioned
a very young
starting pitching matchup ian anderson
just 22 years old last time he pitched
in a win or go home game he was a high
school senior dustin made just a little
bit older at 23 years old and so it is
always a pressure pack game far on the
shoulders of a couple of youngsters here
in game seven back to back four pitch
walks to open the game from dustin may
nightmare start for the dodgers and now
he's got to deal with marcelo zuna oh
one to ozuna
ground ball left side that's a base
hitting through acuna will be sent to
the plate here comes the throw out of aj
pollock and sliding in safe as acuna and
it's one nothing brave
marcelo zuna mixes it up out there at
first base one nothing atlanta and
here's mookie betts 293 in the
postseason
that's the extra line drive to left
that'll dip in front of marquez for a
lead off hit
bottom of the first inning as max muncie
comes up with mookie benson scoring
position pitch all the way from ian
swung on and miss got him and the
strikeout finishes off the dodgers in
the bottom of the first inning we'll see
what the braves batters can do versus
tony gonzalen here in the second inning
paul at a strike here it is to dansby
and he hits one well deep left field
this one back towards the wall and a
clap of thunder from the barrel of
dansby swanson's bat it's two nothing
braves and two-nothing atlanta as he
welcomes tony godzilla into the ball
game
434 feet it jumped got a little
confidence back and he went jack city
right there chris taylor stepping in a
base hit by taylor the dodgers can tie
the score 3-2 swung on and miss strike
three
and taylor strikes out the dodger strand
runners at second and third two out walk
to justin turner now here's muncie who
struck out in his first at-bat anderson
set and muncie lines one fair down the
right field line heading all the way
into the corner counts around dodgers
now have second and third
with two out now here's will smith lying
to right in his first at-bat tying runs
for aboard and smith with a ground ball
base hit into center field turner will
score once he's on his way home and
a collision at the plate he is safe is a
2-2 tie smith delivered for will smith
he has really come on big this young man
has been remarkable the shift was to the
left side of the infield and he just
took it to the right side of the infield
it's had back-to-back walks to start
that inning they got one run but poised
for something much bigger here in the
fourth inning as austin riley climbs in
o-2 pitch that's hitting the air out
towards center field this will dump in
for a base hit ozzy around third here
comes the throw from bellinger here's
the play at the plate ozzy slides in and
he is safe and austin riley delivers and
the braves have the lead again as it's
three to two
tony gonzlan goes two innings plus now
it's blake kreinen's turn and he'll be
facing nick marquez with second and
third nobody out the 2-2 pitch to
marquez he swings and grounds went right
to turner and now caught in a rundown is
dansby swanson
and now
swanson
is tagged out and going to third base
and tagged out is riley a double play
some bad base running and the dodgers
say thank you very much yeah the dodgers
got lucky also because that was not
really a textbook rundown 100
and a new picture on for atlanta coming
on in relief
of ian anderson is tyler matson here it
comes
stop with a fastball but missed inside
to load the bases and it brings up max
muncie here's the 2-2
swung on and miss strike three
a 97 mile an hour fastball
matching is fired up and the dodgers
leave the bases loaded that's a huge
strikeout by tyler lake treynan does
stay in now freeman coming up and now
freeman
the fly ball to right heading on back is
bets he's at the wall he leaps and he
catches another one he's robbed another
one he robs freeman of a home run
leaping over the yellow line spooky bets
is of another planet my oh my what a
play does he have a trampoline out there
to use
left-hander aj minter will come on for
atlanta this is his first action since
he started for the braves in game five
here's [ __ ] hernandez to pinch hit for
jock peterson minter on two and two the
eighth pick to hernandez there's a fly
ball to left field is well hit and kiki
hernandez with a pinch hit home run has
just tied the score at three the eighth
pitch
hernandez hits it out
we've got a new game a pinch hit home
run from [ __ ] hernandez 3-3 in the sixth
inning chris right now is giving you
everything you hope you get from a game
seven which is a gift in itself but tied
up into the late innings winner to the
world series
and the go-ahead run is 90 feet away
with one going in the six seeger awaits
pitch on the way
ground ball weekly out to second ozzy
guns to the plate they've applied the
tag and he's out at home
huge out of the plate and ozzy albee's
keeps it a 3-3 ball game and two down
here in the sixth inning
infield was in and ozzy was able to
glove it cleanly had some time and a
good strike to the plate pretty awesome
stuff what chris martin is doing they're
pitching in game seven in the nlcs in
arlington base is empty two out he faces
bellinger martin's 23rd pitch bellinger
with a fly ball to right field
cody bellinger has just given the
dodgers a 4-3 lead and the dodgers who
hit
118 home runs during the regular year
have just hit their 16th home run of the
championship series and the dodgers lead
it 4-3
and martin had tried to stay away from
the power cody belgium he kept missing
away and then he threw a fastball
right down the middle you make a mistake
bellinger loses it into the stands
though it will be up to aureus here in
the ninth and now with a chance to lead
the dodgers to the world series the 2-2
swinging in the ground ball to short
backhanded by seeger throws to first one
out in the ninth curious on two and one
and dansby swanson here's the pitch
swinging a ground ball to short quieted
seeger throws to first two out
one
out away austin reilly coming up riley
first pitch fly ball centerfield
bellinger is there and he's got it and
the dodgers advance to the world series
for the third time
in the past four years
the team with the best record in
baseball all year long 43 and 17
in first place
since the 13th of august are the
champions of the national league